is hard at work this time of year and he
may need a little help if you are
looking for stocking stuffer ideas the
toy Insider Lori shot has some great
ideas
Lori what do we put in those stockings
this year we're going to start with
something that all of them are loving
and dying to collect and it is our mini
brand so it's the Gold Rush collection
it's for food and for their toys so what
makes this different than the other mini
brand every single thing they collect
will be in Gold so whether it's their
favorite food like the cinnamon or their
favorite toy like the Crayola crayons
it's all in here and it's adorable so
there's always over 30 to collect of
each you know Santa he came a little
early to my house and he stuffed my
stocking and he put this in there so
these are cute little plush you can
collect all four of Our Heroes you have
that one I've Donatello here but I have
my other three right here so they are
just so adorable and kids just love them
they're nice they're soft they're
collectible and how beautiful are these
so I know it's a little big for the
stocking but I fell in love with these
and I had to share them with you so this
is our LOL surprise but this is our OMG
fashion show collection each one has
over 320 mix and match looks and their
outfits do cool things so there's like a
drawstring here and if I pull it I can
change her outfit just by pulling this
up and then it can go inside out I can
turn this hole down into a fun little
mini skirt lots of Fashions lots of
other surprises inside the box and
they're gorgeous another thing that I
know the kids always love is slime this
is cupcake surprise and what I love
about this is you have all of these in
one nice little package so there's five
little containers here each one has a um
a compound four it has a fun mix in
because kids love to get their hands in
here mix stuff in crackle it and then
there's going to be a surprise unicorn
in there too or something fun to put
inside this is so cute when you have a
box and you don't know exactly what's in
there it's always a surprise tell us
about this one
and kids love the surprise but this is
aphmau so these are the me Mouse and it
is a mystery plush this is series two
and it's because of um this it's the
number one game female-led gaming
channel and she's got this love for the
feline so she's got all these animated
cats and these are sort of what they
look like so they're adorable you get to
open them up it's always a surprise
they're so cute they're so soft and
again you're going to want to collect
them all there's eight to collect this
one is called pop it pro so that bubble
crate is gonna meet electronics and
become a game now because what happens
is we push it out and now you're popping
and you're so you're actually playing a
game there's three modes of play in this
one you can play solo or with your
friends so you can challenge them
there's a pro mode there's a pop it and
pass it mode so really really fun uh the
last two this is fun it is the perfect
size for a stocking stuffer and it
sounds like they do some really cool
tricks what are these they do so this is
called hashtag boneless so what you have
is your little character and your your
it's on a skateboard it comes with
another piece so you can change up the
skateboard once you push it down what
happens is which is hard to do when it's
not on the there we go I don't know if
you can hear it but it's notarized and
it takes off so it'll take off it'll do
tricks you can also buy arenas for it
this is our Tamagotchi picks party so a
few things are going on here for one
thing it has a camera so you can
actually take pictures with your little
Tamagotchi creature and now it can go
into party mode so you can go into the
party room and be the host or invite
your friends in
um and then everyone can get together
you're going to be snapping all those
shots and of course there's fun new
games like cooking games so it really is
just a lot of fun